Logan spoiler jockeyed right my friends
Logan has been released in theaters I
have seen it twice now and if you've not
seen Logan this is my Logan spoiler talk
you have been warned I'm going to gush
about the spoilers in this movie so if
you've seen Logan or you just don't care
about spoilers they stick around let's
do this that's good you want to see my
spoiler free review that does exist I'll
put the link below you can click on that
check it out go watch Logan come back
after you've seen Logan say no you can
hear me talk about it and we can relate
and you can do the comment section thing
so this is not a review and I'm
addressing things in Logan I found
interesting that are in the spoiler
territory I'm gonna start out with
Charles Xavier I was surprised when they
took Charles Xavier in this movie he has
some sort of degenerative brain disease
that gives them seizures and when he
gets seizures he sends out the psychic
shockwave it just locks people up and
they'll die
it affects Logan a little differently
because of his immune system you can
kind of like truck through it and give
Charles Xavier his shot twenties they're
all hiding right now and Logan's keeping
Charles Xavier ultimately sedated even
Falmouth Xavier was like oh you're
keeping me here waiting for me to die
[ __ ] you Logan
Logan's personal reason for keeping
Charles Xavier around us this is a
simple fact that he is what he had
childhood Xavier is Logan's only real
link to anything good he's really had in
life so he needs Charles Xavier be alive
not as simple as just waiting for him to
die and when we meet Wolverine he's not
in a good place to this dude is sick
even limps around hobbled yes shitty
posture I mean I have shitty posture he
had worse posture he's sick he can't pop
his claws out as much as he used to his
healing really isn't working like it
used to the movie doesn't really give
you the causality of it you just know
he's sick and the adamantium is making
him sick but you don't know if the
adamantium has just been in his body for
so long
that it has nerfed his immune system
it's the cause of his immune system
going out or maybe the older he gets the
less he heals and does the metal in his
body is poison as metal that's not
supposed to be in the body would be
point is he's dying in the adamantium is
why when they come across a little x-23
Logan wants nothing to do with her you
can tell he knows who she is he knows
that she's his daughter or Lee's clone
daughter but he wants nothing to do with
his know I'm Howard I don't want to do
that I'm not taking her to North Dakota
I mean the band of douchebags roll up to
collect x-23 a few of them go into that
building hear screams and gunfire and
then she walks out holding a really
soggy football oh no there's not a soggy
football that's a head she rolls it it
fumbles around like
of all and then she proceeds to rip
[ __ ] [ __ ] into everybody when people
die it's it's so brutal cilium
gratifying seeing it in Logans world
that's was because Rosen's world is a
sick shitty tragic one the world of
violence because violence dude has no no
good it's going to be a very raw story
the injustice in this entire thing would
be if Logan was rated pg-13 fast
forwarding a bit talking about psychic
shockwaves that scene whether in the
casino and then the psychic shockwave
just goes off and Logan's trying to get
upstairs you see the squad of douchebags
that a found Xavier and they have guns
on them and Logan like has his claws and
he's in the wall you trying to like get
to them that's when you seem just
putting cloths through field this one
hit goes to the back of his deep head
kick out his face I was beautiful that
was its art but that scene where that
dude has is done and you know the
ripples are happening induces goes it
looks right over at Logan you're like oh
that guy's frightened as Logan
sequentially just kills all these dudes
brutally and those frozen there and he
gives Xavier his shot and everyone just
dropped awesome saying I love that thing
once thing I'm kind of heartbreaking is
when you realize Charles Xavier killed
some x-men possibly all of them ran it
in the movie there was some genetic
crusade against mutants so that I'm sure
did a lot of it but when Xavier had his
psychic freakout moment in that casino
you hear the rightie on the radios like
there was this wave of paralysis and hit
a lot of people kind of like that thing
that happened in Westchester New York
you're like Westchester New York is
exactly where Professor Xavier school
for the gifted was and the radio goes on
to say the last time it happened in
Westchester New York it killed a few
people including some any luggage turns
off the radio I'm pretty sure the price
was x-men Charles Xavier killed the
x-men it's tragic that Logan this weapon
of war never got a real life and the one
that tried to give him a real life and
family ended up taking a lot of that
away and again he's also blacklisted so
these two are really old tragic tales
living together going to where
ultimately all roads led us to the same
path it is a farm scene okay if you're
one of people you hated the farm scene
in Avengers age of Ultron worry not this
is absolutely positively how you do a
farm thing they run across this families
are really nice they help them out on
the highway when their horses got loose
is like hey come over to our place will
feed your free meals earlier alright
yeah it's cool to hang out there's a
family moment with this family it's a
really sweet scene Logan even takes care
of a problem that we're having because
family is a black family Hillbillies
roll up smelling of cheap whiskey and
kerosene logo sex [ __ ] off bat breaks
weather knows a snapshot gonna go away
and no good deed goes unpunished for
this family I was like they're not gonna
kill this family I mean you know these
guys are hot on their trail but there's
no come on you got to draw the line oh
they die all of them like the children
the parents they're all dead and also
another tragic scene because Xavier is
in bed he's like Oh Logan I this is the
best night of my life I didn't think I'd
have this nice life don't [ __ ] you Logan
and you look at Logan you're like he
looks different
he looks younger is this a vision and
then look new Logan just pops with claws
out in Charles Xavier is chest and then
just kills them straight-up Xavier has
his heartfelt moments these lugger like
Logan and Logan stabbed him through his
mind's eye when Logan's picking all be
like Charles it wasn't me it wasn't me
so it's like you don't know Charles
Xavier dies thinking Oh Logan finally
did it I finally pissed him up enough
bored him enough right in the middle of
nowhere who I could have another seizure
episode he's going to kill me it's
really dark [ __ ] but Xavier goes out
Chyna goes out like a punk just like he
gets stabbed in the chest and then it's
done however that's one of the tragedies
of a story like this is that these great
people that we know so I chose Xavier
it's Logan it's Wolverine it's Professor
X larger than life itself all intensive
purposes no one's probably going to
remember them but there's this new look
it's like this Logan clone and we're
like okay the kids the x-23 is it didn't
really work so how about this we just
take Wolverine and we have him now and
at first I was like okay because I don't
know why it reminded me of Superman
pretty but it reminded me of Superman 3
this really did it a lot better than I
felt Superman 3 today because this fight
young Wolverine versus old man Logan
it's a man versus the Beast
Logan vs. Wolverine and the Wolverines
the Beast
it's [ __ ] winning it means love and
getting his hittin on this young
Wolverine by me he is in his prime is
like flat heel flat heel yeah
Bam Bam Bam Bam - looks like [ __ ] ow
he's not healing like the young one do
like fist to fist man to man toe to toe
young clone is going to win it was
brutal there any time to think it's
taken as like terminators like you take
it out it's like no it's not down it's
not out it's not gone and the comic book
element of like other comic books in our
world based on our
adventures but their x-men comics that
we have in our world the whole fourth
wall breaking things that actually
worked out really well in this movie as
I was hoping it did but anything though
when Logan sees that the coordinates for
this Eden written down on that piece of
paper that has the money wad and it is
the same coordinates that's in the comic
book I was like Isaac Mendez Ramirez
anybody know it did he write the comic
book is that where the ground with is
but they didn't go that direction they
went the direction of this lady got the
coordinates from this comic book which
means it's a lie there is no Eden
whatsoever this is a [ __ ] mission
ironically it does exist because she
read it in the comic book said that's
the meetup spot so they all go there so
it exists in their world because it
existed for comic books I thought that
was a really cool neat bit of irony
right there and I mean it was the kid
there was a part of me that was like
it's like Mad Max 3 just like
Thunderdome but it totally did work for
what they were doing and so it's good by
the end it totally paid off but while
you're there the first time watching it
I was like this is my least favorite
part of the movie doesn't change the
fact that it ends in that forest fight
slaughter scene which is the greatest
father-daughter moment ever
straight up man that is bring your
daughter to work day right there happy
father-daughter day folks BAM and then
we have the last Throwdown between Logan
and the Wolverine and it is a hard
wondered if the slaughter Logan is old
as [ __ ] he takes that juice and starts
ripping people up in the forest but by
the time he gets to the clone it's worn
off he's now old man Logan again and
it's going to hurt and it does I mean
this gets a truck flipped on him bite
you the earthbender kid doesn't matter
big clone just takes Logan and just boom
puts him on that tree stump luckily
Logan and his hole of depression had the
adamantium bullet it never really
explains where it came from you got to
think oh did he get that from Stryker
the striker thing in x-men origins
Wolverine point is when little x-23 a
little Laura takes it and shoots the
clones blows has his head up he just
drops to the ground and dies which might
not even kill I mean the comic books
we've seen Wolverine come back from like
a speck so who knows maybe it's still
alive I doubt I think for the sake of
this story in the movies it's dead what
it does do is it shows us the x-men
origins Wolverine was [ __ ] because
when Stryker shot Logan in the head just
made a little hole and that was nice as
brain heal this was like no bone
that x-men origins Wolverine like oh
don't worry his brain will heal ah oops
I guess not [ __ ] I just blew his head up
into moving it's heartbreaking dude it
all comes full circle the whole of this
story is a story about a man who never
had a real life we never had a chance of
happiness because this organization took
him turned him into a weapon he never
knew pain he was never shown how to be a
part of a family even when he was among
Charles Xavier at work through
appointment that all fell to [ __ ] the
dude has just had he's been in this [ __ ]
then he sees this little girl from him
who is put on the same path but if he
can get her there if he can get her
across the border and put her in her
paradise to hang out with her friends
away from all this [ __ ] maybe she can
have an actual normal life with families
us maybe he can die with some form of
respite he saved a bit of himself that
lives on and her it's super sad and
tragic you can tell look by the end he
totally gets this and she's crying she's
like Daddy and I dude I saw man it's
such a brutal so I just lose it I said I
can't help it man appear up it's a
saddest thing you just saw them bond
over blood and killing people and it hit
you right there cuz now he's going down
he even says he's like don't be what
they made you when he's dying she's
bawling and then he's great last words
he's like so this is what it feels like
and then he dies yeah that's like the
one mysteries ever had he's never
experienced death or maybe he's talking
about that's what peace feels like or
absolution or actually saving another
human being in the end he's probably
talking about that now he's buried there
I'll of this there's a cross at his
graves as you know is customary for a
lie below someone died out here boom
cross and then as she's walking away she
turns back and she takes the cross and
puts it on its side and it makes an X
because it's like a cross is not Kim the
XS he's an X man I had a religious man
you want to see me fall like a baby guys
is that Logan's the movie I mean just
Logan had layers to it it had death it's
the first movie since the dark nights
that I saw rose like that comic book
movie is different than other comic book
movies that's not to say the connotation
or label on a movie of comic book movie
is bad not at all you know I love me the
comic book movies but I'm saying once in
a while a comic book movie comes along
where you're like that is a solid well
put together drama that half
to have comic book characters in it Dark
Knight slogan they do that honestly if
you've seen Logan already watching the
second time as better than second time
there is no post credit scene though so
I stayed through the credits limit okay
there is I heard there was there's not
actually pretty neat so this movie
doesn't need a post credit scene I was
really afraid y'all succeed if they got
post credits thing I don't want to see
Logan's claws or hands come out of the
grave or some [ __ ] got a weird putting a
post credit scene after a movie like
this you know it's a pretty heavy-handed
move you're in tears by the end you
don't want to be a post credit thing
that is actually smarter than well shoot
guys aren't all the spoilers if I were
to talk about everything in his movie
that I consider a spoiler this video
would most certainly be about an hour
and a half long so in a world rise I'm
just not going to do that those are some
of the things that sounds really
interesting really intriguing I love
this movie so I want to know in a world
room maybe you've seen Logan at a point
where you're watching the spoiler video
who is your favorite scene part moment
in Logan whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]